[Music]
once the United States was filled with
beavers up to 250 million beaver ponds
once peddled the continent that's enough
water to submerge Washington Oregon and
California but by the beginning of the
20th century after decades of over
trapping by fur traders just a hundred
thousand beavers survived the slaughter
transformed North America's waterways
beaver activity building dams and
forming ponds and wetlands slows the
flow of water captures sediment and
reduces erosion after beavers and their
speed bumps disappeared thousands of
streams straightened and deepened into
gullies many streams stop spilling onto
their floodplains preventing them from
recharging water tables some streams
dried up altogether now researchers are
attempting to rebe ver these run-down
valleys with Beaver Dam analogs or BPA's
a row of peeled logs form its frame
lattice of woven willow sticks comprise
its body DDA's provide powerful
recruitment tools starter kits that
offer similar services as natural beaver
dams while also helping the paddle
tailed engineers settle where they're
most needed between 2009 and 2012
researchers installed 121 Beaver Dam
analogs Long Bridge Creek a 45 kilometer
long stream with an Oregon's Columbia
River Basin the goal was to convert a
drastically simplified stream into a
complex one sure enough wherever they
put structures beavers came and set up
shop by 2013 beavers had built 115 new
dams and fortified nearly 60 EDS and
with the Beavers came results as the
streambed rose water coursed once more
onto the floodplain tripling the creek
submerged area and increasing side
channels by over 1200 percent in Wyoming
PDAs are creating wet Meadows for
sage-grouse in Utah their sub irrigating
cattle pastures in Oregon the rebuilding
eroded Sam
for all that momentum however Beaverdam
analogues continued to hit snags many
landowners as well as some agencies
still consider beavers tree felling
field flooding ditch clogging nuisances
and look askance on any effort that
invites their colonization last year
alone the US Department of Agriculture
trapped more than 23,000 beavers but the
idea is slowly taking hold
ranchers in California's Scott Valley
watershed are warming up to beavers and
they're human imitators persuaded by
water tables that have risen by as much
as three feet and reduced irrigation
costs happily beavers have returned to
countless North American waterways to
lend a helping hand or paw
[Music]
you
[Music]